one of the props we see in the first
scene of lights out is a magnifying
glass this was before things you missed
existed but it could be a little hint to
the audience that they might be rewarded
if they took a closer look at some of
those smaller details details like this
little figurine version of the
antagonist of the short film lights out
the 2016 lights out is an adaptation of
David Sandberg 2013 short film created
for the who's there short film challenge
at the end of which this happens in fact
the opening of the feature film is
almost like a large-scale recreation of
the original short using the same
concept of creating suspense while
switching between light and darkness it
also features a cameo from the star of
the short film Liu tallow stain Stan
Berg's wife who is also referenced in
deleted scene she has appeared in all of
San Berg's films some of which are
seized added with other connections and
lights out stick around to the end of
this video to hear about them
welcome to things you missed after
submitting his short film lights out and
uploading it to the Pony Smasher YouTube
channel in December 2013 David Sandberg
was awarded Best Director and the video
gained significant traction on YouTube
to the tune of nine million views by
June 2015 the Swedish couple was
contacted by several agents and
producers including this guy Lawrence
Frey who wanted to turn it into a major
motion picture produced by James Wan
which probably explains the abundance of
mannequins as we know Wan loves his
mannequins I had the opportunity to see
lights out early at VidCon 2016 which
was especially inspiring because pony
smasher had ridden the YouTube wave to
the Hollywood directors chair which is
exactly what I wanted to do it was also
one of the best movie watching
experiences because the audience was
just so into it surprisingly considering
it was a roomful of creators I think I
was the only one who actually filmed
anything from the QA 20 final and I
notice every day a Film Festival from
Glasgow called us and asked us if they
could show lights out at a horror
Fistful of that any recently oh yeah
this is so cool we need to go to let's
go now this is our blade and then the
day after that I did it cause so it's
like well maybe skip go straight let's
get into the things you mess
[Music]
as Paul is air heated into the darkness
we transition into the title card which
uses the very same logo created for the
original shorts that now has lighting
applied to it as the logo recedes into
the dark we see two small glimpse of
light which represents the glowing eyes
of the antagonists Diana one of the
problems with shooting silhouettes is
that you can't tell which way the person
is turned or where the person is looking
for that and just for the creep factor I
wonder our creature to have ice that
reflected light kind of like a cat from
the logo we go straight into the room of
our protagonist Rebecca and the first
thing we see is this poster which kind
of represents a cartoon version of Diana
another poster in her room is this band
poster for slagged which is a Swedish
metal back and you may remember David
and Lodz I came over from Sweden there
might also be a deeper meaning here an
IMDB there's this trivia point that says
slacked is Swedish for extinguish and to
extinguish the lights is to basically
turn the lights out later on we see
another Swedish metal band poster for
the band egos you could say that Dianna
is kind of like a ghost in a way I mean
she certainly has ghost-like properties
such as disappearing in the lights
there's also an Avenged Sevenfold poster
in her apartment for their 2013 album
hail to the king 2013 is when the lights
out short was released but I can't help
but feel it would have been better to
put something related to their 2001 song
darkness surrounding the next character
we meet is Rebecca's half-brother Martin
who's seen wearing a Batman shirt and
also has a Robin figurine a couple of
Justice League posters and even some
Batman pajamas now this could be the
studio Warner Brothers trying to promote
their IP but it also might be a sign
that the director is a little bit of a
DC comic fan himself after all he would
go on to direct Shazam as his third
feature film in 2019 there's also sort
of a connection to his second movie
Annabelle creation which came out in
2017 because the name of Martin school
is Palmeri Elementary as you may know
I've already covered the Annabelle films
here on things you missed and in the
Annabelle creation episode I mentioned
the Easter Egg Palmieri's toy shop which
I connected to the first Annabelle film
where we see the Palmeri apartments but
the name Palmieri Elementary and lights
out doesn't necessarily mean that pony
smasher predicted the future he actually
ended up clarifying in the comments that
the name Palmieri is actually a
reference to a woman named a Victoria
Palmieri who works at newline I also
want to thank David for going back in
time and adding the letters cz to the
eye chart right here I made it
finally made it in Hollywood but
speaking of connections with his other
films there's one major theme that has
come up in each of them so far and that
is foster care and what's out Martin's
parents are taken out by Diana forcing
him to live with his half-sister
there's even an alternate ending where
she officially becomes a foster parents
you are now first a parent and if you've
seen his other movies they both take
place in foster homes there are also
similar ideas that Rebecca has to deal
with
she has abandonment issues because of
her father abandoning her and her mother
when she was a kid that's why she's
hesitant to make things official with
the guy that she's been seeing in Brad's
she's afraid that she'll get attached
and he'll also abandon her she won't let
him stay over leave anything at her
place or meet her mother
Brett defies her expectations by staying
with her even after seeing how
disturbing her family life is as part of
her character arc is her learning to
appreciate him as more than just a
friend with benefits there's even a
moment where he goes to pick up food for
them and while he's gone there's a knock
on the door in an alternate take found
in the deleted scenes she simply says
it's Brad's with the take used in the
movie does a better job of saying
something about her character at that
point where she just sees him as the guy
bringing her food but he's actually kind
of like the biggest champ in any movie
probably and even after it appears that
he's running for it he's actually going
to get help from the police maybe one of
the most telling parts about Brett's
character is how he supports Rebecca
even through her investigations of her
mother's past was Diana at the mental
hospital where we'll find even more
things you missed
you
[Music]
as I mentioned earlier in the video
lights-out was produced by genre veteran
James Wan in music and video games the
producer is always very creatively
involved but the involvement of a
producer in a movie can vary however it
seems that Juan did actually offer some
creative ideas for lights out on the day
we were shooting at James Wan was on the
set and he came up with this idea of
having to Dianna's in one long unbroken
shot I couldn't help but notice that
Rebecca's apartment shares a very big
similarity to the motel in James Wan
2007 movie dead silence we're a flashing
sign from the street fills the area with
a red light that goes on and off giving
glimpses of the movie's antagonist
coincidence omage or idea from James Wan
himself we may never know unless David
tells us in the comments Rebecca
discovers a box of old files from
Mulberry Hill the mental hospital where
her mom first met Diana this was teased
at earlier on in the opening when we saw
Paul holding his wife's file from
Mulberry Hill which describes the damage
of the Diana presumably placed on her
there seem to be many examples of Diana
attacking other patients Rebecca listens
to an audio tape recorded by Sophie's
doctor who is voiced by David Sandberg
[Music]
there's also an article that she
discovers about the life therapy
treatment tested on Diana and at the
bottom it's cut off but we see that the
chief of staff at mulberry is a doctor
sand something I'm assuming that that
might say Sandberg but I guess it could
be Sandman Sandman was another DC Comics
character and it looks like Rebecca has
a couple volumes in her apartment after
attempting to have him stay over at
Rebecca's House Child Services puts
Martin back with his mother and together
they watched the 1958 film Auntie Mame
which I have not seen but I looked it up
and and yeah that's uh that's what movie
it is but the interesting part is what
line we hear from that movie
ciao how can you see with all that light
again I haven't seen the movie but it
sounds like she doesn't like light it's
much like Diana from this movie this
ties into the idea that Diana represents
Sophie's depression and mental ailments
you often hear someone who is depressed
say that they're in a dark place but I
will cover that more in Diana's episode
of horror history they all prepare the
house for the night to keep themselves
in the lights and safe from Diana one of
the tactics that they use is putting
tape over the light switch which is
another reference to the short film and
which is of course also on the poster
there would be one more reference to the
short later when Rebekah and Martin are
locked in the basement and Martin goes
through the box of Halloween decorations
to try to find a way there's a mask in
there with the same whites
lazy eyes as the monster in the short
film meanwhile Brett is upstairs trying
to save them but he gets attacked by
Diana and buys himself some time by
shining his phone lines and we briefly
see his phone background which features
the word scare assault which seems like
a bad name or something but it's not any
bands that I'm familiar with he also
seems to have a scare assault phone case
in any event I think we can all consider
this movie a scare assault considering
all the scares in it and there are some
awesome techniques used in the finale
like Brett's using his car keys to shine
the light on Diana and the muzzle
flashes from the police guns making her
disappear momentarily that's all the
things you missed that actually made it
into the movie but there are a couple
things I noticed in the deleted scenes
as well so I'll just mention those
quickly in the same article that I
mentioned that was written by Lata it
mentions a police officer named Erik
Heiser which is the name of the
screenwriter for light sound there's
also a reference to the art director
Shannon Kemp who likely named the Kemp
apartments in reference to her own last
name diana is one of the best original
horror movie villains in recent years so
join me next week as I analyzed the
entire history of Diana Walter in the
next episode of horror history remember
to subscribe to see Z's world for new
Horrors every week bring that death Bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one
assuming we stay inside
[Music]